[Música]
Alemania no solo es un país muy rico
también es un país famoso por funcionar
como un reloj suizo y fabricar cosas de
mucha calidad es al menos es la fama si
alemán es bueno
el caso es que durante las últimas
décadas Alemania experimentó uno de los
milagros económicos más importantes de
toda la historia os hemos hablado ya de
ello tanto aquí en visualpolitik como en
nuestro canal hermano visual economic
hoy el país germano es sinónimo de alta
productividad empresas muy prósperas y
unos trabajadores muy cualificados sin
embargo tiene un problema un problema
potencialmente muy grave y del que
todavía no os hemos hablado su
incapacidad para atraer mano de obra
cualificada alguna vez te has planteado
irte a trabajar a Alemania seguro que
muchos de vosotros lo habéis hecho pero
seguro también sois muchos menos que los
que habéis pensado en Reino Unido Países
Bajos Canadá Australia o no digamos ya
Estados Unidos pese a ser un país muy
rico con muchos empleos y Aparentemente
la oportunidad de construir grandes
carreras profesionales Alemania no
parece ser un sitio nada atractivo para
los trabajadores más cualificados rankea
mucho peor que el resto de sus países
comparables no llega al extremo de Japón
pero es una anomalía una anomalía que
queridos amigos amigas siempre es un
problema pero que lo es aún mucho más
cuando tu población en edad de trabajar
Se está reduciendo y la pregunta es por
qué demonios Alemania resulta un destino
tan poco atractivo para los extranjeros
más cualificados Qué puede suponer esto
para la que tradicionalmente ha sido
considerada la locomotora de Europa Qué
está haciendo el gobierno para remediar
esta situación Pues bien en este vídeo
os vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas y quién sabe
quizás al final te plantees mudarte al
país germano O tal vez no arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos amigas Alemania es un país top 10
y con ello nos referimos a que casi está
omnipresente entre los 10 mejores países
cuando miramos prácticamente cualquier
índice de bienestar y desarrollo pib per
cápita niveles de escolaridad grados de
productividad acceso a servicios básicos
etcétera etcétera Pero sus fábricas de
Última Generación sus modernas aulas
educativas y sumas que envidiable
inversión anual en desarrollo Tecno
Industrial no tendrían sentido si no
existieran profesores ingenieros médicos
operarios y profesionales que pongan en
marcha todo este inmenso aparato
productivo y el problema El problema lo
podemos empezar a ver perfectamente en
esta gráfica
según cifras oficiales de la ONU a
partir de este 2023 la población alemana
empezará a contraerse de una población
total de cerca de 83 millones de
personas en la actualidad la previsión
apunta a que se perfora el piso de los
80 millones en 2047 y el de los 70
millones para la última década del siglo
no es una contracción tan salvaje como
la que se espera que se produzca en
países como Japón o Corea del Sur pero
aún así es relevante desde el punto de
vista económico estos datos básicamente
significan no solo menos población
también población más envejecida y por
tanto mucha menos mano de obra
disponible
lógicamente todo esto responde a cambios
en los patrones de natalidad pero hay
algo que también puede incrementar el
impacto económico de este declive la
falta de retención del talento sí
Alemania recibe mucha inmigración eso
Seguro seguro que todos lo habéis
escuchado sin embargo en esta historia
Hay un problema cada vez que un
trabajador alemán altamente cualificado
se jubila no es fácil sustituirle porque
como veremos en Alemania no sobra la
inmigración pero sobre todo lo que no
sobra es la inmigración cualificada y la
pregunta por tanto es quién puede
decirle que no al gigante alemán porque
se prefieren otros destinos Estas son
las preguntas cuya respuesta tenemos que
averiguar para hacerlo lo Primero lo
primero de todo tiene que ser entender
cómo Hemos llegado hasta aquí
[Música]
las primeras campanadas demo
no es un caso aislado la mayor parte de
los países desarrollados y también otros
no tan desarrollados como China o Rusia
están experimentando un acelerado
proceso de envejecimiento demográfico y
ojo porque este proceso no solo reduce
la mano de obra disponible también eleva
considerablemente el gasto público
pensando bien pensiones sanidad
dependencia El caso es que Alemania
entendió el problema y sabéis que
comenzó a hacer sus deberes muy pronto
Ni más ni menos que hace ya medio siglo
y la década de los 70 se produjo un
punto de inflexión en Alemania su
población nativa comenzó a reducirse
esto es el país entró en una fase de
crecimiento vegetativo negativo como
podéis ver a partir de los años 70 el
número de defunciones ha superado cada
año el número de nacimientos para
compensarlo Alemania comenzó a impulsar
la inmigración como podéis ver también
el número de inmigrantes que llega cada
año es por regla general mayor que la
pérdida nativa de habitantes esto le ha
permitido al país mantener su
crecimiento demográfico durante todos
estos años
todo depende de la llegada de nuevos
inmigrantes Y si os fijáis en el gráfico
veréis como a principios del siglo XXI
sonó la primera alarma la llegada de
inmigrantes se desplomó a comienzos del
siglo XXI casi toda Europa crecía y lo
hacía más que Alemania el país germano
no era ni mucho menos La única flor en
un jardín de prosperidad cada vez más
amplio y eso lógicamente tuvo
consecuencias la competencia frenó la
llegada de Nueva mano obra a las
Industrias germanas La pregunta es qué
es lo que hicieron pues lo cierto es que
los alemanes se lo tomaron muy pero que
muy en serio el gobierno sabía
perfectamente lo importante que era
atraer El Talento joven y mantener la
expansión demográfica para evitar que
tanto la economía como la propia
seguridad social entraran en crisis y
para lograrlo además de promover
activamente la inmigración también
Hicieron cosas como esta fijaos 1 de
enero de 2005 entra en vigor la primera
Ley de inmigración alemana a partir del
próximo año los nuevos inmigrantes
tendrán derecho a participar en clases
de alemán financiadas por el estado y a
recibir una introducción al sistema
judicial a la cultura y a la historia
del país el gobierno ha destinado más de
200 millones de euros a este plan las
medidas funcionaron
[Música]
el número neto de inmigrantes que cada
año llegaba al país prácticamente se
triplicó de 73.000 en 2004 se pasó a
212.000 en 2008 y no sólo eso para el
2016 se tocó uno de los techos
históricos en materia de población
inmigrante
432.000 personas no alemanas se
trasladaron a vivir a este país Claro
que lógicamente Alemania es parte de la
Unión Europea y qué significa eso pues
que el país está sujeto a la libre
movilidad de personas y trabajadores
cualquiera de los miembros comunitarios
puede convertirse en un país rival por
la mano de obra una competencia
creciente que Alemania no parece haber
sido capaz de gestionar muy bien
[Música]
tanque pero no
a partir del año 2013 la llegada de
inmigrantes Alemania comenzó a
desacelerarse de nuevo y lo que es aún
peor según los informes de la ocde el
país era cada vez menos atractivo para
la llegada de profesionales porque Y
esto es importante no todas las personas
son iguales lógicamente desde el punto
de vista económico la cualificación
cuenta y eso es lo que explica que la
ocde hiciera esta advertencia fijaos 4
de Febrero de 2013 migración laboral
Alemania está abierta a los graduados
pero la inmigración es difícil para los
trabajadores medianamente cualificados Y
por qué decía esto la ocd Pues
básicamente por esto atentos a los datos
Alemania es uno de los países de la ocde
con las barreras más bajas a la
inmigración para trabajadores altamente
cualificados sin embargo el número de
trabajadores inmigrantes de fuera de la
Unión Europea y del área de libre
comercio que recibe es de 25.000 al año
alrededor del 0,02% de la población la
tasa de trabajadores inmigrantes
cualificados que reciben Australia
Dinamarca Canadá y el reino es de 5 a 10
veces mayor es decir supuestamente
emigrar a Alemania era relativamente
fácil pero aún así los trabajadores
cualificados preferían y aún prefieren
otros destinos ya sea por el idioma por
las normas o por el estilo de vida El
caso es que Alemania no es un destino
popular
[Música]
claro que esa no es toda la historia una
encuesta realizada por el International
institute for management development con
sede en Suiza descubrió que la
percepción que tenían los empresarios
alemanes sobre la facilidad para
contratar talento internacional era más
bien pobre es decir que el informe de la
ocde no reflejaba fielmente toda la
realidad al parecer los trámites
burocráticos venían siendo un problema
desde hace ya una década en cierta forma
la legislación para traer inmigración
cualificada que trataba del año 2005
estaba quedándose obsoleta en
comparación con los incentivos que
ponían sobre la mesa países vecinos por
eso entre los años 2018 y el 2020 el
parlamento Alemán comenzó a realizar
varios cambios en la ley cambios para
dar mayor facilidad a Los profesionales
de fuera de la Unión Europea por ejemplo
se facilitaba que los inmigrantes
llegaran sin un contrato sin embargo
justo entonces la pandemia cambió por
completo el panorama
la propia agencia Federal del Trabajo
viene realizando desde el año 2013 un
seguimiento de lo que las autoridades
denominan como profesiones cuello de
botella esto es área del mercado de
trabajo donde las ofertas laborales no
consiguen cubrirse con los trabajadores
disponibles en 2020 esta situación se
enfrió pero a partir de entonces la
tendencia ha regresado cada vez más
campos de la economía alemana son
incapaces de lograr los trabajadores
cualificados que necesitan de hecho se
espera que en 2023 este indicador bata
récords
la reactivación económica tras la
pandemia junto al creciente
envejecimiento demográfico están
llevando al mercado laboral alemán a un
contexto cada vez más crítico mientras
que la demanda de trabajadores no deja
de crecer el número de inmigrantes que
llega cada año se ha reducido y no
digamos ya el número de los inmigrantes
cualificados para que os hagáis una idea
de lo que estamos hablando según las
estimaciones del instituto económico
Alemán de Colonia A mediados del 2022
había ya un millón y medio de vacantes
en este país un dato que se espera
crezca con fuerza Durante los próximos
años la situación ha llegado hasta el
punto que algunas áreas comerciales han
tenido que empezar a prestar sus
servicios de forma reducida y esto es de
hecho lo que explica noticias como esta
25 de julio de 2022 Alemania recurrirá
trabajo de extranjeros temporales para
paliar la escasez de personal en los
aeropuertos alemanes las fotos de
viajeros haciendo largas Colas en los
controles de seguridad del aeropuerto de
düssel dorf a principios de esta semana
mostraron la magnitud de la escasez es
decir la economía alemana necesita
urgentemente mano de obra de todo tipo
según cálculos del instituto de
investigación sobre el mercado de
trabajo y el empleo de Alemania hace
falta que cada año lleguen un mínimo de
400.000 personas para mantener estable
la población activa
[Música]
eso ya es un problema pero amigos lo de
la mano de obra cualificada libre eso ya
casi es una especie en peligro de
extinción en este país según una
encuesta realizada en diciembre del 2022
7 de cada 10 empresas están faltas de
mano de obra especializada y no solo eso
es que para colmo Alemania se enfrenta
ahora a otro problema ya no es que
lleguen pocos trabajadores cualificados
Es que muchos de los que había se están
marchando es decir que el país está
sufriendo una fuga de cerebros Y eso es
algo que pone en peligro la formidable
industria que alimenta el mayor motor
económico de Europa pero volvamos a la
pregunta que nos hacíamos al principio
Cómo demonios es posible que no haya
casi profesionales que quieran vivir y
trabajar en uno de los países más
desarrollados del mundo Dónde está el
problema pues atentos
[Música]
los tres pilares de la refuga de
talentos
si Tratamos de ir directamente al centro
del asunto podríamos decir que alemanes
se enfrenta a tres grandes problemas
cada uno de ellos concatenado con el
resto por ejemplo en primer lugar no se
puede pretender que el stock de capital
humano procedente de Europa sea eterno
[Música]
según las cifras oficiales se había
perdido el 9% de sus habitantes en las
últimas tres décadas macedonia del Norte
El 10%, Bosnia herzegovina el 24 y
Albania el 37%. y algo muy parecido
podríamos decir con Polonia o la
República es bálticas entre otros todos
estos son países que han perdido gran
parte de sus jóvenes mejor formados y
más cualificados y claro Europa es un
continente muy envejecido así que la
cantidad de trabajadores cualificados
disponibles para ser captados por las
empresas alemanas es limitada digamos
que la cantera ya no da más de sí
en esta línea muchos expertos estiman
que el efecto inicial de las
ampliaciones de la Unión Europea ya está
terminado quizás Ucrania fuese la única
excepción pero este país también ha
sufrido ya un enorme Éxodo de
trabajadores cualificados sobre todo
lógicamente jóvenes por eso Muchos
analistas apuntan a que la búsqueda de
talento tiene que mirar Más allá de las
fronteras continentales y sabéis que
esto es exactamente lo que hizo que la
Reforma en 2020 de la ley de inmigración
cualificada introdujera más facilidades
para los inmigrantes cualificados de
terceros países por ejemplo se dejó de
exigir títulos universitarios para
aceptar también la formación profesional
como prueba de cualificación una
petición que llevaban tiempo haciendo
los empresarios alemanes Por qué pues
fijaos en este gráfico
por supuesto esa no fue la única medida
también se redujeron algunos trámites
administrativos sin embargo no se logró
solventar el principal escollo que no es
otro que este
el sistema burocrático de inmigración
alemana es sumamente complejo en el
proceso intervienen al menos siete
ministerios sin tener luego en cuenta
las agencias gubernamentales de segundo
orden y los gobiernos locales solo por
poner un ejemplo en la aprobación de un
profesional cualificado interviene en el
Ministerio Federal de asuntos económicos
y acción climática el Ministerio de
trabajo de asuntos sociales el
Ministerio de Educación e investigación
el Ministerio de alimentación y
agricultura el Ministerio de salud el
Ministerio del interior y el Ministerio
de cooperación económica y desarrollo
casi nada
[Música]
esto obviamente plantea un importante
desincentivo para las empresas alemanas
en 2022 solo el 17% de las empresas
encuestadas por la fundación bertelman
contrató trabajadores cualificados en el
extranjero Y si bien las grandes
empresas pueden contratar consultoras y
despachos jurídicos para acelerar el
proceso las pymes se enfrentan a una
barrera prácticamente infranqueable es
decir en cierta forma la ampliación de
la elegibilidad de 2020 fue en la
dirección correcta para empezar a
seducir a profesionales de fuera de la
Unión Europea sin embargo no se preparó
a la burocracia para tal desafío la
movilidad dentro del bloque común es
mucho más sencilla pero al empezar a
incorporar a profesionales de otras
regiones la documentación y los
requisitos se multiplican es
infinitamente más difícil y costoso
incorporar a un trabajador tailandés o
uruguayo que uno polaco Este es el
segundo problema Y por último el tercer
gran escollo tiene que ver con un factor
mucho más complejo el cultural aunque
solo sea por el idioma
en agosto del 2022 la agencia Federal de
empleo alemana puso su atención en este
asunto y sabéis que encontró que la
mayoría de trabajadores que llegan a
Alemania sin saber alemán no se molestan
siquiera en intentar aprenderlo por qué
Pues porque están pensando en marcharse
los problemas de integración idiomática
los problemas para obtener la residencia
permanente el precio de la vivienda el
coste de la vida los impuestos los
problemas para reunificar a la familia
en el país o el choque con la cultura
local son los argumentos más frecuentes
que dan los trabajadores cualificados
que deciden marcharse de Alemania es
algo de lo que en cierta forma ya os
hemos hablado en visual economic para
colmo la legislación migratoria Choca
con un nuevo tipo de trabajo al que
prácticamente no tiene en cuenta los
freelancers Pues bien estos tres
problemas parecen explicar Por qué
Alemania no es un país tan atractivo
como Aparentemente Debería ser la
pregunta es hay alguna salida Qué están
haciendo los políticos alemanes Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
retomando el yopapil
las estimaciones del Ministerio de
trabajo alemán plantean que si para 2026
esta situación no se revierte más de
200.000 puestos hoy ocupados quedarán
vacantes una situación que podría
impactar muy negativamente en las
empresas la productividad y el
crecimiento económico del país por eso
en octubre de 2022 el tema pasó a ser
prioritario en la agenda pública 22 de
octubre de 2022 como Alemania planeará
traer extranjeros cualificados las
reformas incluyen la introducción de la
llamada tarjeta de oportunidad que da
derecho a las personas a buscar trabajo
en Alemania siguiendo un sistema de
puntos basados en las habilidades
lingüísticas la experiencia profesional
y la conexión con Alemania entre otros
criterios y finalmente el pasado 29 de
marzo la ley de inmigración cualificada
fue reformada nuevamente 29 de marzo de
2023 los extranjeros experiencia laboral
adecuada información en su país de
origen podrán trabajar en Alemania
Incluso si esos títulos profesionales no
están reconocidos en Alemania además se
les permitirá trabajar hasta 20 horas a
la semana mientras buscan empleo a largo
plazo por último Será posible que las
personas en posesión de títulos
académicos o certificados profesionales
permanezcan en Alemania hasta un año
mientras buscan empleo funcionará esta
nueva reforma solo el tiempo podrá
decirlo la pregunta ahora es de
plantearías vivir en Alemania te
gustaría hacerlo De qué forma crees que
este país puede impulsar la llegada de
nuevo talento déjanos tu respuesta en
los comentarios y hablamos debate y
ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante No olvides darle al botón de
like y suscribirte a visualpolitik si es
que aún no lo has hecho un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]